apparently I've just been told there's
something called female condoms not
Kahn's girlfriend just told me that she
what she's a sec are you becoming a
sexpert is that where you're where
you're headed done maybe maybe gone well
don't email but sex this might well be
people that I talk a lot about it but
don't necessarily do it like on sex
drive which he talks about sex quite a
lot I would imagine that this is all
ongoing general I mean it's all
happening
how do female condoms work can you
answer though I think that just female
just cosmonaut pocketers pray you don't
it's not like what you just like hang on
what can I use this second maybe I was
like female condoms did is there like a
new way of doing that they use I don't
know whether they still have fever comes
they did huh female condoms they were
just like big round like late sexy whole
Ibrahim the male sexy stuff yeah I'm a
county ladies and gentlemen the return o
causes girlfriends yeah as well she's
like your number one fun I just wanna
let you know that they are taking in
something quite interested in a really
mysterious formula they're having sex as
an experiment and in newspaper writing
an article about it okay how interesting
I mean to just say the intro of that is
a little bit questionable because what
you're saying is they're having sex as
an experiment
a couple of different couples who
usually do it in the evenings so they're
getting them to do it in the mornings
and people are doing mornings they're
getting them to do in the evenings to
see if it feels different Conger said
it's all the same I've rubbed off on
them not literally
I guess this massive weird image in my
head at that point yeah sorry
Mon I'm not a morning person to be
honest with you get your coffee in the
morning yeah
the thing about sexes although is that I
always kind of think that it's a bit
contrived if you're having to kind of go
ahead and do it we actually use now
because normally would happen
organically not in a field but it would
just happen you know but now you haven't
a schedule it now on is pencil it in is
the first day do you have sex every day
that was this morning was too smart this
morning the morning yeah do you feel
different was it a bit okay how often
you have sex yeah all right Khan likes
to roll over and die basically
you're not even meant to as a guy as a
guy what's gonna happen first of all is
it desire to kind of leave because when
you think about being human before you
know it's have sex
hence my guys can ejaculate really
quickly so if you think about it when
people talk about private or attract
relational OC like people get worried
about it but if you think about it in a
survival context it was really important
to kind of get in there yeah ejaculate
run because you know you could have a
saber-toothed tiger claw at your back
otherwise all or arrival or arrival
exactly
so at the end of the day when you think
about the male and female rhythm that's
one of the reasons so I've just like to
say for anyone out there there will be
someone because it's a male audience
mainly who's having premature
ejaculation problems just think of it
this way
in the wild hundred arrows or whatever
you lot would have been safe so managed
to get actually in because you guys
never sure I Jack you late before the
longish hair god then it would be no
good to no one
it's okay you can really deal with
premature ejaculation don't even wear
your hair on the gong any males
listening is completely okay Lots how do
you do not about this yeah I mean I've
talked to a lot of people about sex for
stock to do a lot of sex the
relationship work but young people have
like been a passion of mine forever like
literally from day one of me starting
working young people sounds wrong saying
young people who are question of mine
but like you know twenty fives were my
main oh we have worked for a long time I
have massive love of working with that
client great particular like
hard-to-reach groups of young people who
don't play it really easy to talk about
stuff I mean young people struggle
anyway a lot of the time because
everything feels just a bit embarrassing
but definitely with the younger young
people I would sit down and kind of have
conversations about that and they
wouldn't necessarily confide in you with
an ass over time this they get to know
you they would start confiding with you
so when it comes down to premature
ejaculation you know sex is horny and
like when you're getting it on with
somebody you know when you're thinking
about all of that by the time you
actually meet them particularly if
you've been thinking and anticipating
you might get it on and then you've got
all the things going around your head as
a teenager anyway by the time you
actually get to go inside you're often
so wound up that it's very very quick
that's not premature ejaculation that's
just genuinely starting the sexual
rhythm what we see is sexual problems
and dysfunction is where somebody is
consistently having sex and not managing
to get to a point where they've been
lasting more than 10 15 20 seconds and
that's really distressing for guys but
the thing is this about training all
this is about training it's like
anything so how would you work with
somebody and if you're listening and
you've got a problem with a Jack Layton
and you're not having sex because you
don't want to feel like you're failing
one of the things that you can do is
offer desensitization so it's about
holding on to your [__] or masturbating
and then before you actually get to a
point of coming stopping so you start
controlling it I mean anybody wants to
last longer in sex can do that anyway if
you watching porn and porn is making you
feel stimulated and you feel like really
aroused don't look at the really
hardcore porn
to figure about my kills she does
everything without so right now she's
literally got an imaginary [__] hey
if you just hold on to it it's
substantial your imaginary cousin but
yeah you desensitize it so you know like
the teaching guys to masturbate in
condoms because a condom kind of puts a
little bit of a barrier there morally
right it's not my turn on and also
because a lot of people on the other
side learn to kind of get afraid of
condoms that go on and you lose your
hard-on
so again teaching you to get used to the
tongue but that's really important so
sex is something you can train yourself
to be brilliant at but it just takes
work sometimes and I just think people
are so scared of saying you know I can't
last more than five seconds to the maze
because it makes gonna take the piss and
instead of us being supportive people
often get the opposite of that so people
like me exist and people like websites
that are there for people involved in
that kind of concern they exist for
people to go and find that out that's
what I love about this era of Jesus when
I was growing up when I was the stuff
you were told when I was a young girl
obviously I'm only like what 28 or
something you know really you know I
don't live with my own internet but when
I say William go
I remember getting told that
masturbation harmed you yeah I mean that
is damaging whoa can you imagine that
like when you're like 30 don't be doing
that when I was like nine she said like
Oh be careful doing that obviously
walked in on me really really happy with
me saying that alone that's one for you
children well they're watching well the
friends day your mom is a wild one
yeah who didn't do anything like that
and so she was 13 and ready just 17 that
apparently if it's completely natural
thanks mom
have you ever had a guy who's been in
therapy with you and I'm sure this was
something like I'll fall in love with
you a bit do you know what
countertransference that's erotic so
transference and countertransference
it's erotic is quite common I haven't
necessarily felt that much of it in my
time I think my
personality is one that you just kind of
get over any of that pretty
instantaneously and you might want me as
your sister or your friend but I think
on a sexual level guys haven't
necessarily as clients felt that way
women sometimes have had that towards me
I think I'm kind of quite non gender
orientated in the way that I present
myself and I'm kind of somebody who
doesn't really have a fixed sexuality
and I'm quite open about that so I think
because of that maybe people who are
female have had more of a incidence of
reflecting that I'm safe to kind of
project onto but I've not necessarily
explored it with clients I've never felt
myself in a position to have explored
other things like when I found a client
that I really hadn't doesn't like me or
when I found a client that feels
particularly conflictual towards me but
then I'm representing something for them
like a mother or a sister or a father a
teacher or whatever
so I've deconstructed those kind of
situations but I've never been in the
situation with God that person wants to
get it on with me and actually very
fortunately I've never been in this
situation where I've worked in therapy
and had those conflicting feelings
because I were watching The Sopranos and
Tony Soprano and there hazarded
therapists and like his relationship
with the cross and was named one point
he's like convinced he's in love with
her I'm like she's like no you're not
it's the the results you get and
she wasn't it one of the things is this
one is really attractive yeah but that's
another reason why has not been too much
in my career is at the end of the day
that is another issue you know and I do
sometimes look like I fell out of a car
when I go to my therapy I've never
really dress off and I'm not very very
good at looking very feminine and all of
those things but again this morning for
a reason though you're in TV yesterday
this morning somebody said why don't you
like wear your normal clothes to just
like rock a pair of heels and your
skinny jeans and your striped t-shirt
it's like because by the time they
finished with me at this morning nobody
not even my family recognized me like I
don't look anything like do they really
do you open yeah I look like I'm either
going to a wedding or I'm hope we're
going to get an MBE or an OB a when I'm
finished
you know and then like a get my jeans on
straight away you know every the only
time I got recognized it people are like
do your kids go to the same school as my
kids you know and it won't be it will
just be that they've kind of watched a
crime program or something
so no I don't have to worry about any of
us Scofield definitely likes to make up
he looks kicked in it he loves it
do you know he's facing person makeup
artist oh my god I say I knew it I knew
it is he always the creases in his skin
always look really accentuated and I'm
like what's gone he tell you what he
looks pretty good for his agent Holly
I'm not joking my Holly looks prettier
all the time really bizarre see I think
Holly um she started off a lot more in
her personality and looks towards men
and now she's gone family-oriented see
I'm not I feel less attracted to her
yeah well unless she gets cuz I'm like
mm she's gone so mumsy now that i'm just
saying now this is must really help
wasn't honestly if you know who realizes
I know I sound like the massive massive
thing for our cuz um she's my type of
the bomb in that but um that's sort of
unfortunately Holly if you watch on that
ship still for you hopefully she can
deal with a husband and kids well we
might find out that I could sleep
she's definitely gorgeous don't get us
wrong but um Nash they've changed the
whole image like so now adorned I see
her as like a mum I don't say it as like
a sex symbol yeah huger sees a sex
symbol mmm who'd was to draw things what
ESCO Lawrence would be myself oh yeah
with her really yeah just once yeah
what's she like yeah I'm she was yeah
which is she's really into body
positivity and I always find it quite
challenging to watch people have
photographs self visit themselves taken
because like she has a party I don't
know if you've noticed in her selfies
she's her face she has a face yeah all
models had like 30 or 40 photos taken
there's many of you natural selfie yeah
and then chose log that was like always
cold
like she is I'd let the interviewer I
think and not even just because she's
straight she'd love to do that with you
she's I think I've got a good chance of
that she has she liked my pictures a
tiny tiny way and then like a really
like pop pert massive bottom not massive
sight she's not a plus-size model she's
halfway though and she here's what she's
got a big bomb yeah she's she's not so
she there's no plus I know she's
gorgeous but she has a slight shot is
small enough by it to be a model model
but she's not bigger than she is she is
very very natural and I think you
definitely should get her and she's
really into like kind of the whole body
positivity and white is thinking about
just being yourself and all that stuff
yeah which is easy to set them down in
us like this sometimes I do think myself
like as much as I love her like yeah
it's easy to sell oh and you look like
you pet like Java at the same time that
might be an interesting one city
regarding transference and
countertransference with you to whether
you actually would want to sleep with
her at the end of it or whether oh yeah
well no just it's an interesting one we
should have that on we should definitely
have that we have an analysis of whether
you can put you in search of the
journalist you can talk about you've
probably run through some people because
sometimes when there's a person who just
hits that everything that you saw yeah
like super moto but with a big bomb in
the public eye he's probably rich yeah I
mean yeah honest care your face is quite
sort of girl-next-door II and I think I
quite like that she looks like a nice
person yeah no but she could be for all
I know she could be a tall [__] I don't
think she is nice but what I'm saying is
I'm a big fan of the friendly face yeah
she girls who love [__] I find I don't
know I just
it puts me off insert that whole thing
about wretched resting [__]
yes but some people just really
genuinely have that face and it's not
even that they're a [__] it's just
they've got that face you know younger
people as well I think the younger
generation now we're just wearing their
emotions on the face course I see that
so much Meryl don't hide share anymore
this like my sort of my parents in their
parents generation there was stiff upper
lip like you'd have to put a face on
that was the whole thing
now if someone's having a miserable day
are they [__] let you know you know I
mean it's no one holds back anymore the
amount of times I've set the women in
Michael can you just [__] pretend
like you're [__] happy honestly [__]
six like yeah I can't pretend to
understand like the problem with me is
I've got those traits as well so when
I'll be around someone who equally
doesn't hold back what I kind of clash
with them I don't like sulking behavior
looking really really difficult but
that's because I think secretly aside
that I have that potential well like I
can look at something they'll instantly
know how I feel and really that's quite
like dangerous it's like quite
disjointed silk'n to me is part of what
I'm hearing a lot more about in
relationships where you'll find one
person who's I want to say how to an
upbringing where they're being taught to
communicate their feelings and on a
mature level know how to open up and
they always seem to be saddled with
someone who has no idea how to
communicate and then and you're I'm
finding a lot more in relationships
people I know of or in relationships
where there's a parent and a child like
this basically in that particular turf
throwing quite a lot of therapies do
this but usually you kind of have to
find adult adult so addle addle is the
ideal state mmm so if I look at like my
mom and me when I was a kid I was really
rebellious and she really struggled to
kind of like me so we fell into a very
very clear even though that was the
correct dynamic she was a parent I was a
child she was really critical parent I
was really rebellious child yeah so as
you grow up the I deal with your parents
is you because
all right but I have to like literally
leave the country for three years right
to be coming at all so we got to know
each other in absence if that makes
sense and now our relationships amazing
so when you come back together amazing
well we wrote to each other so like the
first page that I ever received of her
was like a page of airmail you folded it
into the envelope sent it the last one
got for 17 pages of a4 long
she came visited me in barley backpack
with moving my dad and I just realized I
miss them and I want to go home so that
was what happened there but in
traditional relationships genuinely
traditional relationships when you look
at your dynamics like so now what you're
talking about there you turn into
potentially critical parent which is my
dad for example my dad wasn't in my life
from when I was nine years old about 19
how so he literally did he just go one
day well no there was there was a
falling-out it within the family
basically and my dad hadn't liked you
probably others and it's cool but like
he hadn't really ever stepped up to the
players glad you know that his focus was
on him and the women and it's like me I
was a a womanizer
like big-time yeah so I don't know where
I got it from no I moved in all these
different women's lives and whatever I
mean you always kind of felt like you
were in the place behind yeah I was I
would come round on a Sunday so I was
suddenly leagues are thing and it's cool
but that's just how it was you know I
mean I'm not bitter about it but at one
point I think the right decision was
taken for me to be removed from his life
and when I come back into his life later
it's weird like I now feel more mature
than him yeah yeah in a sense that
because he hasn't played his cards right
that he was dealt in life in my opinion
and he'd be the first to [__] admit
that whereas I feel like I have so it's
almost like if I was have a conversation
with him I feel like I'd be more likely
to give him advice then he would be to
give me advice generally yeah totally so
what about even your mommy you and your
mom were really close all the way yeah
yeah that's totally the different total
different really like that's like I'm
still
child-like general I'm saying but let me
dad he's just he was just wild I mean a
total wild man and you got a lot of them
I suppose like where the dad is in and
out of a kid's life and there's there's
men out there like that I guess and it's
always gonna be like that's like genetic
though sometimes one of the most
challenging and damaging experiences for
human beings is abandonment and
attachment issues you had a really great
relationship with you moving from what I
can tell no but like I remember once I
was having a conversation with a
girlfriend and I was like 16 and she was
like yeah your problems you've got
abandonment issues and I remember like
being like what and like I'd never heard
that word before and she was like yeah
you've got abandonment issues of worried
like people are gonna leave you cuz cuz
would not have a new relationship were
you diagnosed I [__] like I was like
you're right
like I just I'd never even considered it
no well you don't consider when you're a
boy and loads of people don't consider
it yeah yeah and the problem is then
they get into relationships and have
problems throughout the relationships
and they're either really rejected
because they think to themselves screw
this I'm not invested if I invest
somebody's gonna leave me or they get
really needy because they need to make
sure that that person is not gonna leave
them and then that often becomes
counterproductive you and the individual
can't give them what they need because
nobody can be a parent yeah you know
that's the problem that's why addle
addle is really important
where are you now in your relationships
I mean yeah I think that you're like
somebody who's like you obviously are
like you've got a loyalty complex about
you even if you don't feel that you have
because that is just like part of you
knows you just said that you're loyal
you know if somebody's good to you
you're going to like be good [__] I'm
proud of the [__] I look after that that
person and like like even in me work
life and that like I'm around people and
I stick with those people and I trust
them yeah makes you open to being used
that's an annoying process that you get
used to I'm definitely I leave myself
wide open to many people regularly and I
just trust that they think I'm a good
enough person to be loyal Awards and be
the consequences of crossing me always
are not best-case scenario analysis but
towards women so in the last sort of
like two to three years I'm I've evolved
like I'm definitely more of all of a
sudden something's happened where I've
gone like or [__] you don't have to lose
it I'm like you can just talk things out
and like um now at a point where I very
rarely gang angry and in that and if
anything what I've noticed is when I had
the argumentative side of me and I was
immature so what would you Japanese say
something happens where there's the
first phase of an argument where someone
does something wrong that can usually be
I would elevate that most of the time
and go straight a new race voices I'm
not wrong you have to admit you're wrong
I want an apology then and I'd sort of
be a dead horse and dissonant ill I got
my apology and I was right now I if
someone's in the wrong I keep my calm
but what I'm finding is being the calm
one it winds the other person or even
more and I'm like well [__] me I love I
should be getting rewarded for the fact
that I'm now being calm and discussing
things rationally and if anything it
just used to piss the other person off
so because women like just oh just women
just all women every culture every
environment every lifestyle every
parenting just any woman anywhere any
age I mean this and I know it's a
generalization I know there's there's a
percentage that won't fall into this but
what I'm gonna say is the vast majority
of women that I know that I've ever met
in my life when they angry or they love
a good shout they love a good argue they
look like back and forth rah rah rah and
then at some point within that they'll
be like and they'll settle and then
they'll come and talk to you and be like
you know a poly
whatever and it'll all be saw it but
when you don't give the woman that
opportunity to rah rah rah they're
[__] frustrated it really pisses them
off it it depends on you complete style
so like I don't shower
my husband is a shouter right it's like
a proper shower like he'll say to me oh
say I swim ta no I can see because it'll
be it'll just be if we met just like me
kind of thing and what you were just
saying about that shouting then so when
I met him if we get into an argument
he was just like use words that I would
never use I would you insult you call me
the c-word so I'm a little bit ever
insult are you stupid
he would never be oh my goodness he'd
never don't get me wrong that's what
most people do he would never say
anything about like the way a lot to
anything like that but you just called
me like I mean like for example I'd say
you're [__] stupid
yeah like it like shout like I just like
well I'm not gonna discuss this now and
it's really not appropriate these
speakers be like and then he would think
that was patch and I think but that's
not patronizing it's just the fact that
I'm just gonna explain how I feel and
I'm just gonna let that be and then he
realized that in the end that you don't
need to win like nobody needs to win an
argument like the beauty of human nature
is that everybody sees it from their own
perspective so the art of conflict is to
be like as long as it's not that
something's black and white wrong right
if you go and cheat on me like my ex
husband cheated on me you're wrong now
it doesn't matter how much I take into
consideration that our relationship
might have had flaws like anybody's are
the truth is you did something that
black and white it's wrong you can't now
talk your way out of that choice does
that make sense so that's a black and
white right that's one thing I'm really
guilty of is in in a relationship this
is like evens that haven't evolved past
this this is like an ongoing problem is
if I have a massive massive Rao or I get
trapped badly in here in any way where
I'm like [__] I've been like I've been
shafted day
and especially if it's repetitive I hold
a grudge like there's a real so what I'm
saying is I almost start the
relationship a full ton of love and
every single time yeah they really hurt
me horde it it goes down what and oh and
don't until eventually I get to almost
empty and and what happens for me is I
don't forgive like this nor it doesn't
replenish it doesn't go back it
literally is like when I meet someone
it's like you've got this use it wisely
like and because the more you [__] me
over and hers the less I'm gonna feel
about you because it's almost a defense
mechanism for me of just cut that off
like just every time just a little bit
we're talking about so that first stage
of abandonment issues yeah yeah which is
you waiting for somebody to let you down
oh yeah wait and then you don't give him
a chance to apologize and move forward
the art of like conflict is you know I
am somebody who will have those
black-and-white moments in my life I do
but for the most part for me it's like I
sorry so sorry and as long as their
behavior changes it changes so like if I
was in a relationship with you and you
felt upset because I let you down and
then I go oh my god yeah I did let you
down didn't I and I need to do a B and C
when I don't a B and C you have to get
that title I suppose the thing is I've
never been in a situation where anyone's
really ever redeemed themselves the key
is that you you're leaving the tank to
be emptied when that person doesn't
deserve any more of your time like the
deal with relationships with great
relationships that you just screw them
over when they're not nice to you it's
like what are you willing to take and
that's the other thing about attachment
and abandonment
it leaves you vulnerable and it
sometimes makes you question your own
self-worth it makes you question whether
you do have value and when a parent
might leaves you it doesn't matter how
ok the circumstances were that led to it
or how the adults around you were making
those decisions for the right reasons or
whether the partha wasn't the motor
father the point is the message is that
you're not worth it it doesn't matter
that I'm a fundamental I don't listen
you go I can look back at that and I get
it I get it I'm not you're not you
dealing with like a manual boil
yeah I think so one of the things that's
a tree died is like so for example when
I got back in touch with him was well
why didn't he just send us a birthday
card
I didn't have a birthday card for like
ten years from when I was like even
though did you fight fight for me
yeah it's forget forgetting you though
the big fundamental question you're
asking is why didn't you fight for me
and what he needs to say is I am sorry I
didn't because then that's okay it's
like because at that point you can go
you know what in this world everybody is
trained their best but some people's
best just isn't my god I'm not good you
know that's the key the key to conflict
the key to life in general for me and I
look like a really peaceful life and it
doesn't mean I don't have ups and downs
but for the most part I'm kind of like
quite calm and I'm quite happy and don't
get me wrong I have to work it God like
anybody listening to this and thinking
why am I so depressed like you have to
work it I've had mental health issues
I've had lots of problems in my life but
what I'm saying is you can get to a
point where you can maintain a pretty
simple positive outlook and you can
reframe the [__] because I spent my life
for a long time as you imperson to be
massively resentful what you're talking
about hoarding resentment where I could
like literally as a young person I was
gifted with my vocabulary from a really
early age it did not transmit to any
other area in my life it did not even
connect with intelligence it was just
this amazing ability to just string
words together and seem to be quite
convincing which meant that if you were
in a relationship with me whether you
were a friend or even a parent I could
make you think that I was right because
I could take some bizarre argument and
almost make it seem like it may permit
ability instead of spinning shin right
missile I could do that and that meant
that I spent a long time winning I lost
everywhere else in my life from
relationships to jobs to whatever but I
kind of was right and then I realized
that that's the worst way of being like
nobody has to validate me being right I
just have to like acknowledge I am but
that comes from a belief that I have
Worth and with you like it or otherwise
and for anybody who's lost a parent to
somebody who's lost a parent to death
there's a young person or some of you
has been in a situation where they're
never won't knowing their mother or
father or an adopted kid you know all of
these kind of things they cause a
fracture that doesn't mean that that
person's damaged it just means it causes
a fracture like anything and it heals
one way or the other
some people just get really resilient
but most people it's like it gives you
questions and I think in life we have to
figure out what questions we need to ask
and have answered I'm not saying that
the people around us can always give us
that answer but that if we ask it in
North either to ourselves or to the
people who shared experiences like we
have been doing we find it so for me I
just got really resilient no actually
I'm I'm a really resilient [__]
I mean like how also I rate myself very
highly like and I don't mean that in a
bad way but I just like I have
self-worth yeah and I have a standard of
like what I will accept well you like
that and it never goes below that really
apart from when people do crap to you
and then you let then do it again what
you're saying is maybe in your personal
life that's the only area that isn't
completely I think if I really did love
someone I would allow things to get
worse than what it normally would oh
maybe maybe they shouldn't get worse but
what I'm saying is one when I let the
tongue go down that's me yeah you don't
I know you get so for example if I'm
holding if I'm holding on to that
person's hand that that tongue is going
down and I just I've cut my own arm off
yeah I'll cook I'll hurt me in order to
end this whole [__] really I mean don't
you think the age is like a massive part
of it well lately for me I've hit a
point where I'm like oh [__] like I'm I
am Who I am no this is this is where I
want to you've got to be fully
accountable for me responsible but at
the same time I just think that a lot of
us don't do the work to look back on why
we are the people we are and who formed
us and it's not a blame game like I
think they're not bringing that's it not
a blame game in the last in the last
couple years I like this sometimes I'll
be driving along and I think [__] me I'm
so lucky like I like a mom who put so
much into a sort of thing because
otherwise like because I know people who
haven't had that and then I realize
where they are and I like literally
think my whole life has almost been a
domino effect and like she pushed the
first domino it you know I mean if it
wasn't for that it wouldn't have been I
wouldn't be where I am now so hello love
that is real and pure I mean it's
complex in any sense love always is but
if it's like given to you
in a way that you feel just like
unconditionally I accept it even if it's
just have one person that's even if
they're not any directing so the whole
reason and gun on camera in front of a
million people and just not give a [__]
is because in my head as long as I'm
loved by my mom why do I give a [__]
about what anyone else thinks so that is
exactly what drives me as much as I
might be in front of a camera talking
about something mental in me Hayden
demure that's what's driving me children
I mean I think for any mom to have like
as soon say that is like a legacy then
you just dream of like I want my own
boys to do that just to think you know
what my mom just completely knows who I
am and sees me for who I am
I'm sure I'm [__] well work though
yeah yeah I've got great kids I've got
great kids bought the hilariously funny
and they're also really emotionally
literate the thing about me bringing my
boys was it was just just speak speak
their truth you know be them be who they
are
well I I do live in a comedies I can't
live in a comedy house I don't take it
seriously I mean like parents like take
it really see you do a podcast together
you and him so like we just talk
bollocks
subscribe I'll leave the link below if
you know seriously groaning anybody some
news right I don't buy it on the thing
today going Oh Mike you know great I've
just like it's like every degree I like
I'm sorry the person who's like
listening cuz you're obviously a great
listening to this show and like amazing
for being lovely it's well love positive
people but I was just honestly I'm
telling you right they'll be so
disappointed just me moaning
usually interrupted by animals and dogs
really yeah I'm not like you dogs come
in here every now and then but that's
another story
no I'm joking I'm sure you were saying
that there's been a lot of times in your
life where it could have gone one way or
the other
Mike do you feel like sorry I know this
is you interviewing me but I saw you on
the fact that like how do you feel now
Kim that like because you're a role
model god that's a big word doing no but
no because the thing is you can't how
about you you might not feel it and it's
not even something that I think he's a
legacy you have to feel I'm being honest
with you but you are like you have like
a huge amount of people young men young
women not all you
and women either you know older people
as well and they listen to you and it's
not just about the humor it's like about
the journey by the bin we used some of
those people from pretty much day one so
they're grown with you and your brand
like so how do you feel like just
looking at that and reflecting on that I
think the weird so when it hits is
couple of times in the past week I've
pulled up at traffic lights and it was
like around like school time or whatever
and there's like 30 like kids just
around me car what and photographs
others and stuff and that's like this is
[__] mental it's like the traffic
lights have gone green now
and there that's like me I way I grew up
and stuff and I'm like god this is
madness like this is like these are who
I was I saw or ten years ago or whatever
that's when I'm like like in one of me
mates was in the car was like this is
[__] man this is a good old schoolmate
who's just doesn't like like he's got a
normal job or whatever and he's like
this is [__] madness like what about
like kind of like when you think about
that what do you think you've seen
change like in the past year since you
began to now both in yourself but also
like in the expectations of people
around you because like things must
change the most change I never had like
a role model at school who was local who
I could achieve what they had done so in
my head I mean I was Alan Shearer but I
was never kind of a Alan Shearer
so I mean I'm kind of like I kind of
hope that this spurs on other lads from
my area too if they have got charisma
and bit of banter give you to Burke or
whatever and because like I've moved
house obviously in the past the yay and
like about four years ago I was in like
a very very small house and like I mean
a very small house in a rough area and
that and I remember having like there
was a there was a week way I was like
[__] I can't afford bread and milk here
like I'm literally [__] got nothing
and it wasn't always like that me life
where I wasn't always but I had like
whatever a bad year or whatever things
one really bad and like driving past the
house now I'm like [__] me like I
started YouTube videos in that house and
like if people could say they'd be like
this as mad so it has been like a real
journey flashes are those reflects like
just amazing though aren't they
you drive past that it's like it's part
of the fabric of who you are thank you
excuse me grounded like some names I'll
just drive past that house and and it
brings back all those memories of like I
remember I used to get up in the morning
and I think all right how can I do
YouTube and makeup what can I do and
learn about and now like every single
day was just like another brick into
what I wanted to create and although
some people might amazing on YouTube I
may put like but you only a Hollywood
film star it's the new generation of
connection by understand bombed on the
sanam I'm just saying in my life this is
a real big moment for me to look back at
that house and say like where I've gone
like what I'd come from because like I
was gotten nowhere fast in that host you
know I mean I really wasn't so without
the thing about mmm I try to get across
to people and I don't think people kind
of understand it that agency that did
you happen to the world so why did you
keep making excuses not to make it
happen like what you did was you just
went ahead and did it that's like one of
the things I see constantly on social
media see a lot of people who are
jealous or envious or they'll kind of be
negative because people are succeeding
and it really unless you have been born
with a silver spoon in your mouth
and no disrespect people who are looking
enough to get that because that's real
you know I mean but for the average
human being like you and me like you
have to work really hard to make it you
have to you know people you just don't
get that you know it's a journey that
gets you there what's been the darkest
times for you will not journey like
because it must have been apart from the
poverty I remember that by the way I can
remember trying to make biscuits then
for me stressing out about money I find
it really horrible I can't new over we
had to cut up here around this month and
then if I don't what happened so like
those doors were pretty bad yeah like a
few people died I mean life along that
way that was [__] such horrible how's
that affected you I mean like I you know
I lost a lot of people were close to me
I lost my best friend and
now remember he's really significant for
me and changes you so what about you so
like my cousin who our basic was raised
like young he was like me brother
basically or me we grow up like we were
dressed the same we did everything the
same you know I mean like was that kind
of friendship and he overdosed and that
was Sarge Wow
23 years old when he died you see like
really really best friend no like we
work because when you're like teenage
lads and that you go off and he was
deejaying and stuff like that who's off
doing his own thing so we weren't as
close but still it was like [__] me like
we were various together like ever
everything he had I had like we were in
competition together our whole lives
like in a good way though you know what
I mean
we would like sleep in the same bed when
we were kids like eight years old and we
talked all night about whatever you know
I mean so like what was really sad
really really sad when he died and I'll
just I just don't really put a fire at
me of like life is so [__] short
like I'd need to take whatever I like
YouTube is why my only I knew what else
was waiting out there for me like with
my other jobs and that don't and I
couldn't go back to that book I was like
I'll not be happy doing that you choose
my only chance of being happy and then
if I get money out of it great but like
I just want to have a job where I can do
YouTube and make enough money to like
keep doing it and and provide a decent
life so and that just spared me on
really I was just made us think [__] me
life is so [__] short just kill it
and that was I but yeah I had some times
where I was just like this is [__]
like or whatever and you know you're
sitting in a [__] room just crying
yourself up and thing and this is never
gonna have and work everything [__] do
you know what I mean I think everyone's
had those moments at some pint or so
yeah that was I think I wouldn't say I
was depressed but I just I was very down
you dealing with grief grief horrible
yeah I think that for me the whole
process of watching somebody ill of die
or being there at the moment
part when you hear that somebody that
you love has died it kind of completely
scrambles who you are and then you
reform but you never reform in the same
way I mean I don't think that grief ever
changes I think that this is
misconception that you get over in the
end and I don't think that's what
happens I think what happens is your
life just grows around it
so like you just have more experiences
and you do more stuff and you go more
places and you have more memories so the
impact of grief kind of is still in that
moment like you know if you look back to
the grief that you've had you can visit
it it was like you can visit it can't
you you can like that moment it's weird
because they obviously other people have
died in me life as well and like I was
talking about can us mom died and for
him that was really hard as well because
it's the guilt he feels towards the fact
that he paid with the surgery that she
had and and not just got me thinking
about grief in general and I was like
thinking about how it was for me and we
are described it was like you were you
were raised with these principles of
basics and life that all right you wake
up in the morning Sunshine's you know
you breathe air you walk like these are
the basics and then you've got a person
yeah who you love and when that person's
taken away from whoever that is to you
in your life it's almost like the whole
world just changing you're like well
like this know they're there then like
this is how things are and then that
taken away I liken to do one day you
wake up you open the front door and the
whole entire world's under water and
everyone's swimming around because
that's how much life's changed for you
and the hard way is is that to you
everything's changing that but everyone
else everything's normal and you want to
solve go up to someone and shake them
and go how can you be walking around
normal that the whole world's just
changed but it's actually just your
world that's changed and and I think
it's not just changed no has anyone it's
like it's significant loss like that I
know I feels like it's it's over in many
respects in there
and I know people have been affected by
grief even worse than me but like it can
take you under like an hour are became
close after there was like three deaths
in a year and I've got really really
like I remember there was one night
where well of couple of nights in one
year where I was just partying to the
point of like almost like self just want
to are self destruct and at the end of
the night I was like throwing up in the
[__] toilet like nearly so I was
talking on be on sick and I remember
thinking cuz I was on my own I was
thinking [__] me like this could be
curtain CLE and I remember like
straining for the life was just to try
and breathe like I literally couldn't
breathe and all the times that year
where I just I really wanted to be dead
like I just I was like just [__] like
I really I didn't are doing me wrong I
wasn't oh you know saying you suicide
how am I going to kill myself let's just
why I mean is I was like life would be
this it would be so much better if I was
just not here like pain so intolerable
yeah and life after the pain is also not
enjoyable so it's like I've got this
pain and I've got a life of [__] hate
what is the point general I mean thought
I got through it and I stayed and I
didn't become suicidal and I just waited
and kept going and eventually found
something that I did enjoy doing and
life got there and when you yeah like
the court of Robin Williams where it's a
famous quote from one of the films
ironically because he did commit suicide
rates and suicide is a permanent
solution to a temporary problem I do
agree with that because I feel like I
could have gone real real down at that
moment and not allowing it to happen
daughter's as down as I fell and waking
up every morning was so [__] and but
just not doing that and not going down
that road was like it did work out and
if I think if people are like and I was
a loyal up you'll say these things but
if you can't just ride the storm it
can't get better in I think the fact
that people don't talk about it a lot
either are you talking about grief and
death and losing people that have real
meaning it's really important because we
don't like the problem with the legacy
of grief is that everyone's going to
have him
like that's the irony like we don't sit
and talk about enough like we need to
talk about everything more I mean even
mental health gets bracketed as mental
health if I don't see the difference
between mental and physical health it's
exactly the same your brains an orc and
it feels things emotionally but it's
exactly the same as if your kidneys
patent if it packs in some real
consequence it's right I think it's
worse and in fact because if we are
anything in this world it's our brain
really that's that we're more our brain
than anything else but the point that we
don't do that conversation you know we
don't have those conversations about
like the fact that every single person
it'll be young people who have listened
to your podcast to have just lost a mom
or I've just lost it out and the point
is that because you can't just go and
listen to people talking about it in
reality you just don't know where to go
I use it even as an adult you'd sit in
there thinking well how do i process
this enormous feeling that's like I've
literally got dread the day just dread
we have people because I opened it up
the Twitter what do you want us to talk
about people saying anxiety and I
remember the anxiety attacks I used to
get and I went to that I went the
doctors and I was like what the [__] is
this feeling I'm Felix planed it I was
like tight chest can't breathe like
nervous I can't can't sleep but also
exhausted and like all these things that
were going on and they were like oh
that's an anxiety attack like you
haven't them regularly because of what
all the [__] that you've just been
through and I remember like for a good
few weeks I was taken is it valium I
submit yeah
diazepam diazepam so that was it and I
was choking two of them don't be
throwing [__] ear cancer say that
like I was didn't I was collapsing just
to get sleep basically like I wore
[__] mess I was like so that base not
mess is it's reactionary reactance is
something that's like all manageable
yeah you said you felt like you were
drowning and that's the thing you know
everybody felt like they were underwater
but actually you're the person and you
just can't feel like you can breathe you
can't do any of that an awful I just
can't get my head around really in a
society that's full of people with the
potential to help each other that we do
such a bad job in the UK my friends or
freaked the [__] I wonder when they know
you're going through that like my mates
were like
if I did me a little bit like about
people say that all the time you know I
mean cuz they were like what what do we
say yeah how do we put somebody's always
okay in the box yeah exactly but at the
same time it's like everybody's got the
capacity to help somebody else it's that
simple if someone is in pain just ask
them ask them why ask them what you can
do you know you don't even need to know
what to do because the person will just
be there where that you want to help
them and even if they can't direct you
being with them in that space is really
important when my best friend right died
she got like we've been best friends
from seven she was like my sister she
really was like we've had periods in our
lives where you know you kind of come
and gone but would always been a
constant in each other's lives you did
everything first every first together
generally knew everybody's first simple
as that now when she got sick I was like
in the state of how do I solve this you
know how do I solve this this is what I
do I'm solution anybody ask anybody who
knows me like my thing is everything
will be alright in the end and if it
isn't alright then it isn't the end
that's my philosophy right yeah so I
solve everything so I was on the phone
to every consultant I could think of I
was looking at new treatments I was
trying to get cannabis oil ordered off
the dark web I was doing anything and
everything so that my friend stage yeah
and it's a really interesting dichotomy
because in the same moment I was doing
everything are you a controlling person
and I think that I have I don't think I
have control issues as in do I feel like
controlling with the people around me no
quite the opposite I'm quite like
liberal in all of my activities like I
just kind of have a really great sense
of people should be allowed to be feel
like soma system we have this constant
argument I love my sister love man I've
got a really good northern family and
we're all close but this consistent
argument she's a teacher like she's a
rocking good teacher you know I could
never commit it's just a bit like that
she's like really really great and my
store my eldest son tied wants to be a
doctor right at the moment it's wide to
be doctor since he was like five years
old and at the time I remember thinking
AHA Jesus it's kind of like a haze
haven't there you know ii mean and all
of that and we went to america my sister
convinced me to go to disney with the
kids a year ago about seven years to old
really if it isn't me i'm not gonna like
lot of cues and if I won't have saved
you some money like use very expensive
meals not the portion sizes I thought
you'd get either they do a huge but
never mind gross
quite a lot of money purchased in the
future so she kind of me was sitting
drinking obviously one night and we got
it would prop her out like a friendly
RAL but she was going I can't believe
you saying that you're not gonna force
him to do his work and I was saying
listen I'm drinking up men you know and
women obviously I haven't got women as
girls haven't got girls but I'm bringing
up men right now and my men that I'm
bringing up have to have consequential
thinking right so if that boy wants to
be a doctor yeah then I'll do everything
I can to help him but I am forcing him
like that's his job that's on him
tonight that's on him and I won't feel
his disappointment I will love him I'll
accept him I'll be proud of him whatever
he does as long as it's happy whatever
he does I'm moved one doesn't know it
was I'm like hey just go do a
communications to do declare and then go
work on yourself I don't care you know
as long as you're happy my eldest one
wants to kind of be it so he'll feel if
he fails he fails so I'm quite able to
let people have their moment yeah but as
a person do I feel solution orientated
yeah
so why in that situation when she was
dying I just wanted so everything out
Annie actually I would say probably
cause more of a distance between us for
those last month's because I couldn't
confront the fact that she was gonna die
you know and it was only the very end
when I was like with her because she's
not many kids and I was with her partner
and we kind of spent the last week and
the last two days I was there the whole
time while she was dying and she didn't
want to die in hospital she'll stay at
home and during that period it was like
a real recognition and ritual of my god
you know really there's nothing I can do
here there's nothing I can do you know
just have to be with her yeah I remember
those feelings I guess I remember having
the sentence um you had of well there's
nothing we're gonna do about this and
it's so [__] final and it's like [__]
like I'm a little bit of a Superman mu
and headless I can always change it I
can I can make things happen that other
people wouldn't believe to be a
possibility how I feel and exactly in
heaven it's like that's it it's gone you
powerless
there's nothing I can do no it's beating
us and what can't changes that's really
[__] also feel like Brister I was
frustrated her I think you fight more
you figure out do you
come on and I can also remember the
thing about death that I think we don't
talk about it like everyone taught us
about this death theme like it's this
great big monster in a cupboard and it's
like this massive like symphony of being
when it happens and why actually death
is like literally the most bizarrely
quick and even the drawn out process
isn't the dyin ISM but you know the
death it's like oh it's supposed to be
that way you know I mean I mean I don't
know if people believe in God who are
watching this or whatever but like I
kind of think it's hard I mean the death
I've been through work or all quite all
of them but uh with with that it almost
relieves you of the pain of having to
see someone slowly deteriorate which I
know a lot of people have to go through
and I feel almost lucky I didn't have to
say that with the people I love because
that's even worse than names you know
yeah but to some degree watching
somebody die also gives you a process to
adapt to it whereas what its sudden
you're kind of like anxiety attacks come
from being in shock yeah like what the
[__] your vulnerability as well cuz you
realize that things that made sense
don't make sense anymore so I will live
our lives even though there are no rules
and nothing really makes sense we live
our lives believing that there is a
thing that makes sense so when that
sense suddenly gets destroyed you just
sit there thinking what makes sense and
nothing does does it make you think
about like this is because I'm not like
morbid subject but like I need some
morbid subjects is a human subject what
is it what do you now think about you
die in one day however after all after
this experience I mean as a human being
like I kind of welcome death as far as
it's a big part of the process as a
person I think that we carry on to some
degree so I'm not really just but I do
definitely have a sense there life is a
temporary thing within me and when life
leaves me it becomes life again so
people ask me why I'm vegetarian I'm
vegetarian because I believe that if you
think about life as an energy field as
an energy force
if you imagine we're all kind of like
don't get me wrong I would not miss fry
we're all computer algorithm and when we
die actually some just take some
earphones often Clarice I'm doing
another thing you know to mean genuinely
it wouldn't surprise me the slightest
it's weird in office it is the fact that
can text somebody in Australia freaks me
out so you know what a-level anything
amazes me but genuinely like on my whole
philosophy is that I think that life is
an energy force that we all belong to I
think that if you get switched and
you're an insect you're here for that
much of a time with you personally yeah
I think I think I'm part of that
sometimes I think myself like how would
I feel if it all ended like Truman
shorts tail like that yeah if it all
ended now how would how would I feel
like I'm actually becoming quite like
I'm about you to the place you've done
stuff like the people that regret life
are the people who feel like they're
never ever did what they were meant to
do that I think must be the most
stifling like emasculating if you're a
guy and destructive you a girl feeling
at the end of the day and this is my big
problem with the way that we bring a lot
of people in the Western world like we
bring people up and I don't know whether
I talked about this a bit last time but
we do bring people up with a blueprint
it's a blueprint it goes you go to
school you go to college you do your
exam and she might go to university you
get a job get married buy a house have
kids die right and it's the completely
broken blueprint that people are
following them blindly because I've had
quite a lot of fun yeah yeah I've
actually got quite a lot of fun in the
last couple years and I know what you
love if you die doing what you love
you've had a life fully lived yeah it's
when you die have you feel but like
you've never done any of the things you
believed in could you imagine that
like I genuinely get up every day and I
like what I do I'm like I'm never gonna
be like a multi-millionaire I don't love
you say I'm gonna win your million soon
like this morning paper going to happen
like definitely on my mood for just this
morning pay a few million a year anyway
did you imagine could you imagine
I can't even award I could not afford to
work this morning
Hollywood movies on a fare pocket yeah
margin yeah imagine you're right watch
me write much anew all those things in
packet a lucky bastard I'm not on one of
those though you're say you mr. mu gives
me new place soon to be fair to be fair
if score feel retainers I could slip in
there no problem for you again report
with your language should I look at some
of the things people who ask this to
talk about certain subjects I love that
you talk about grief hey it's really
really important so many people feel
about it yeah I do a lot just I remember
like I didn't have anyone to [__]
listen to about it alright so we're
going down so the one thing I want to
bring up because I know a lot of people
who listen to this podcast do it during
exams and there's one person who said
that this struggle to they're struggling
to keep their head ringing sometimes
with all the stress that comes with it
because there are only sort of words of
wisdom you've got for that situation
yeah
the thing about exams is that you've
been lied to you entire life so of
course you feel utterly horrified at the
idea of doing them because you think the
world ends if you fail them that's what
the whole process is been bringing you
through education if you fail your GCSEs
or you fail your a-levels so you drop
out of your degree you're screwed the
fact that there are millions of very
successful people around you who've
never even done well in an exam before
is something you don't see you just see
what you believe so first of all reframe
it you are going to still be you the day
have to be done your exams if you have
failed them all there are lots of other
strategies that you can do to succeed in
life the first thing you have to ask
yourself is what do I really want to be
for example if there's a youtube
sensation why are you even doing GCSEs
and a-levels why is it bothering you get
online and start doing it if you want to
be a doctor sure you need to do well so
you rece it for example most importantly
though you stop worrying about your
future it hasn't happened it's not going
to happen because you'll always be in
the presence of what can you do in the
hearing now make things occur
yeah first of all make sure that you're
not spending too much time revising
eight hours and hours 20 minutes take a
break 20 minutes take a break just give
yourself lots of time to soothe yourself
around that kind of educational learning
secondly how can you begin to yourself
you know are you going on walks getting
out with nature might sound a bit
idealistic but we know it helps a hell
of a lot with the way that we
concentrate also it's really good
mindful practice do you do diaphragmatic
breathing if you've got an issue with
anxiety that's where you learn to
actually breathe through the diaphragm
and diaphragmatic yeah if you want to
look it up look up to 7 8 breathing was
bought four to seven or eight for seven
or eight breathing breathing for four
whole for seven breathe out for eight it
just means you can't get panicky just
stops you doing that make sure I know
this sounds like game that's not
something the mother just being able to
avoid it's genuine this make sure you
eat a decent breakfast make sure you're
organized the night before the way that
you set out on the day of your exam is
really important have everything
prepared organization is something I
learned later but what I've realized is
like it's the key to success is a
massive like is the difference maker for
me and I say this across the board is
that the more successful people are the
ones who so make sure that you're
organized make sure that you hydrate it
as well the brain works a lot when it's
got a lot of water in it if you don't
sod all revision if I yeah if he does
that all you're not going to do as well
as you should but big deal you made a
choice so if you want to make sense that
a choices in the future do it but if you
have done your work if you have revised
hard if you are organized and you go
into the exam and it's not a great paper
then there's nothing you can do about
that apart and try you bet she's not
smart or I think my brain is only now
I'm saying ready examples like what the
[__] are they doing making young kids
sex I've seen them as well
the red balls that these kids are doing
now listen I have been in educational
long time I worked in education a long
time people are lying if they are saying
the exams now are as hard as the ones
that used to be they are harder by a
huge amount the Tory government are
despicable as far as I have been there
disappears what I don't
I do not care what they've done to
education it's disgusting is alright if
you go to Eastern you thousand a much
if padding waiting you've got several
tutors then Bank on its system for you
nice so I'm going to be a corporate
lawyer not yourself outright but any kid
from an estate in the UK with a
dysfunctional family which lots of
people have lots of us have right with
poor access to extra education with poor
access to great nutrition right the
system is completely screwed us that's
against them it's appalling and that's
what people need to be saying so kids
who are anxious today right you're
anxious because you are facing some of
the toughest exams that you could ever
imagine and you're right you're right
they shouldn't be having to do it that
way how does a test of memory one day on
a year how does that say that you are
worth an A or B or C it says you can
hold your cool are you happen to have a
good memory
it's got a cool to do with actually know
your subject yeah and that's the key so
that's your like I think I've already
just got like to my full kill button and
say [__] knows and another thing I think
is the model hours that go in like I
like the idea that they have homework is
ridiculous like I thought barn home yeah
I think that's a great idea
teachers would but think about teachers
is right nobody listens to teachers
that's what drives me right as well like
teachers don't want to be marking every
there honestly the amount of stress
people who think they've got loads of
holidays you delusional teachers work so
hard but also teachers want autonomy
they want creativity they want
flexibility they want to be
unimaginative
that's what they want to do and the
capital taking away from them at all the
kids are like I don't know 78 hour days
in school all day like how are they
Lorraine's got any chance to put a lot
of them aboard mean and the thing is you
don't need to be bored education could
be the most amazing experience and
that's why when you've got great
teachers and there are lots and razing
teachers like mrs. Skinner and mrs.
Curran my teachers like they were the
two teachers in the world who thought I
was brilliant and actually I did really
well in theirs because of that so their
attitude implemented my change to some
degree but what kids today a facing is a
lot of negativity like they haven't said
do all of these things I've only just
started enjoying learning my way like I
didn't really enjoy learning at all like
as a kid I found it just boring because
I was forcing myself to learn something
just win the exams basically now like so
Lawrence he's on holiday by the way
fighting
he went to film school so he knows a
[__] turn about editing and all this
sort of so if I want to make a certain
kind of video I have to saw I have to
learn a lot from Lawrence to start off
with giving him a bit too much credit
these days a lot of this is me know just
want to put that out there anyway I've
learned so much like just from an
anomaly in business as well like doing
brand deals and doing sponsorship deals
and I'm like wow this is this is amazing
I'm learning so much but like I've only
just started in China and I think myself
imagine school was like about what you
wanted to learn about what's imagine no
I don't just mean like how to make a
[__] stick us cuz you love Snickers
amazing I just mean alright halfway
between you know like let's just say
your ideal career Rockley like we will
teach you Isaac's I agree the basics of
what that would entail and obviously if
you want to go on a degree level you
can't after ever the way it's structured
is insane like a levels there are people
who take any level to tell me like
they're even worse than a degree because
you're basically doing 3 degrees in a
year it's like insane
I found the a-levels way harder than the
degree do you know what my eldest son
said to me that why can't I just do what
I want to do to be doctor he said
because I want on my 18 I'll be really
sick of being a doctor and you're like
yes a kid of 15 can see that would be
the right foot to do with the Tory
government I'm sorry I'm just gonna put
myself there if you get loads of abuse
about me being a anybody someone's us
what your opinion is okay thought so
thoughts on technology rising and
playing a large role on widespread
depression and anxiety people are going
through whether it's come to light ways
through more the years so this kid whose
us as I know him how do you just have
depression himself and he's a big gamer
and I think what he's in meaning is like
do you think that have you noticed that
that's playing a role in people's
depression in terms of social media so
it's one of those things that subjective
it's almost impossible actually to say
yes the research says that people who
spend a huge amount of time on
are more likely to be isolated and
therefore have a higher incidence of
mental health issues such as depression
and anxiety however one could also argue
that the personality types of
individuals who spend long periods of
times on games may feel isolated and
that's why they spend that time on get
online on a headset chatting to people
and even though there seem to be
depressed it could be that actually
that's even better than it would be if
they were on their own so that is
something that's not very possible to
quantify it someone's asked for your
psychological opinion on Tommy Robinson
tourism and do you when because when you
watch him he swears blindly that he
isn't a racist are you able from your
training to pick up if you think he's
telling the truth and that they are
actual truth and what is sin what Tommy
Robinson is saying is he's not a racist
because Islam is not a race it's the
religious belief is he Islamophobic yes
he has an absolute fear of Islamic
individuals who are definitely Orthodox
so people who are very heavily into
their religion and so he feels that it's
a religion of hate because there are
passages in it which relate to killing
people who are not Muslim it relates to
negativity about certain other areas
that we don't in what we consider a
liberal society to be accessible the
Bible equally does the Torah equally
does you know if you look at any
religious texts it's basically they're
talking about just rip the heads of
everybody and like rape pillage and
murder
written by people in time right but the
difference between the Bible is that we
have to some degree emancipated it so
what's happened is the Old Testament
theological way in the New Testament
theologically are two separate texts the
new Jesus arrived
that's where Judaism separates and
Christianity begins Jesus arrives and
goes guys let us old like dance with
prostitutes and drink together and then
like Christians like yeah let's do that
sounds like a great
yeah and let's just the long hair and
the beard this is it right so that's mm
so CoV for example when you look at
Richard Dawkins who's an atheist Richard
Dawkins says the only religion that you
can arguably stay say has actually
developed to move forward is Christian
and see us in the CV particularly and
less so with calluses and callous ISM
because it fact that they still kind of
believe in quite a lot of the Hellfire
stuff but nonetheless the Hellfire and
yeah you get rid of that and you just
say look screw all religion the
difference between Islam is that it
can't be changed it must not be changed
so it can't do what the modern day
Christians have done you can't do that
it's part of sticking to it the idea so
Sharia Sharia is actually it sounds
terrible when you hear what the bits
that the people are throwing at you that
seemed to be terrible about women etc
but that's not how it usually plays out
in modern world because you know it does
not play they've modified it without
actually rewriting the book sauce there
were like like 1.5 billion people of the
Islamic faith in the world if they
wanted to have the problem with those
man we would be in trouble right so the
problem with people like Tommy is that
he makes a lot of sense when he speaks
he's a great orator he sounds like his
arguments are flawless you're kind of
like yeah the end of it you know if you
are listening you're not an educated
person you kind of like yeah that's it
we're gonna get taken over this idea you
know we can taking over and like that
psychologically is really powerful
because then you're like hang on a
minute
who's taken was over now the fact that
one ultimately that's ludicrous
mm-hmm it's not happening secondly have
you actually there's a lot of people of
the Muslim faith that I personally know
the last thing they're care about is
taken over the world they just want to
live peaceful lives and give the same to
the families that I want to give right
so what's happening is it change it's a
simulator and we'll all the simulate
right now the problem is Islamophobia
exists because we've had horrible things
happen and there are still some a small
section who are playing by the original
doctor look the people who are the
mentals sorry the people with severe
mental health issues in Islam severe
like Isis rocking mentally
rocking do you know to me about the the
Tommy Robinson arrests yeah of course
I've outside a court I mean I think if
you want to give Tommy Robert I'm sure
that whoever was in there must have been
on an I cuz I if you want to give Tommy
Robinson a massive amount of followers a
massive amount of kudos a massive
spokesperson position making Vince
everybody that actually you know what
he's the only one true right this is
ryutarou Benson do a live face book man
let him do it because people like me and
you were never gonna listen to him you
know we might hear some of this stuff
and go oh that could make sense if you
were a B and C but the big problem with
people like him the big problem like him
and the big problem with you like Isis
is they believe their rhetoric to such a
position that nobody else as I say
that's the problem
I'm hearing between your hair in between
and Islamic people Christian people
we're all here in between you would have
people with different points of view
concede at certain points yeah and say
all right you've got us on that one yeah
and that's one thing I to be fair I
haven't really heard I mean I'm not
saying I'm the expert on this guy but
they've us were talk about them and I
really haven't really seen him have a
comment when watch Tommy Robinson have a
debate it is very much trying to win
rather than trying to and I feel like in
a debate there should be an acceptance
that this person from a totally
different walk of life might know
something there I don't and you're not
just trying to show each other down
which is really what Tommy Robinson
debate turns in exactly exactly so it
comes a monologue to be fair I do feel
like sometimes you kinda hasn't got a
choice in that because of the way his
position is and society right now but I
just feel like there isn't enough of
that going on where people are learning
for each other don't get me wrong I
think he stands for a particular belief
system but it's very prevalent in the UK
and I think that people are feeling
angry and the people are blaming each
other for the dissatisfaction intercept
and Happiness and one of the things that
you'll constantly see is like the Isis
group are a group of horrible
individuals who want to destroy the
Western world it's never going to happen
though so we need to stop which needs to
chill out about it because it's never
going to happen they can do what they do
and the outrage comes when he's when he
says a lord of these guys have been
a little girl sexual exploitation it's
it's absolutely profile [__] profiles
at the end of the day it doesn't matter
whether people are uncomfortable with or
otherwise and it's mainly in Pakistan
emails it's as simple as that
you know much like we can say the same
about street robbers being a certain
profile we can say the same about
rapists being a certain profile
unfortunately there's a profile that's
the way it goes
there's a massive profile where you're
more likely to be rate like pedophile
wise by a white guy because there's more
white guys in the UK right so you know
the likelihood is that if you're gonna
have unfortunate basis of being born to
a family where you're gonna get abused
it'll be able to be a white family we
don't ever problems saying it and it's
the same with Pakistani man the
likelihood is that if you've been
sexually exploited much more likely to
be that way it's the way it is it's not
back racism it's not about culture it's
just about fact and it's the same with
any crime crime has a profile we might
not like to talk about it but it's like
the [__] that you [__] but
that's the thing it's factual so it's
like it's not me dangerous statistics
will stop my dear when you know Tommy
Robinson I don't think he's racist I
think Islamophobic DMT and ayahuasca and
how those trips key ok change how you're
feeling about it so do you know anyone
who's done one or have you yeah I know
people who doubled DMT is something that
basically is meant to mimic what happens
to you when you it's the chemicals can
take him from from life stop dying for
example that's one of the things and the
other one is that particular drug that
they use in certain countries to go
through a quick change to my knowledge
of DMT is is a product in a wash go
where DMT is meant to mimic light is the
chemical that is in ayahuasca but I wash
guys are much more natural we have
delivered I mean that's my experience
and you take you take it with people
whom inside give you your money
out-of-body experiences you meant to
connect with your young self the real
self all of that where's DMT is meant to
give you like kind of like or what would
slice Amelie died kind of thing and I
think personally like the first one I
asked you if you want to go over an
experiment with that kind of stuff
because when he do it with people
carefully in a safe environment they're
not yourself out a bit more worried
about stuff that's coming around in the
UK now and because genuinely when I was
growing up drugs were a lot more pure
I really scares me the stuff that you
can get these days now there's a lot of
people dying from one tablet and Leah
Betts was the person who died when I was
growing up that was the one person you
knew everybody knew her name because she
was the kid who drunk too much water and
she died on E and that was really
horrible to hear about she drunk too
much more he can drink too much water
mm yeah that's one of the common death
that's one of the common death you drink
too much water but what happened near
the water like dry mouth or something
honey I think it's like a just that
upset you know it's like what if you're
on an errand appeal everything yeah bit
obsessive you know moon Mars you know
for the last deaf I heard about her blue
turn to acid [__] me
blitz into acid [__] right yeah I did
the other right so with that with me
like I'm since the beginning of time man
has changed the way that they think and
feel by using drugs right I would you
wanna know about my policy if I was just
to put out that legalize and regulate
and tax just do it we don't do that yeah
well I think the whole idea behind DMT
is to open you might expand my
consciousness it's about look it's a bit
like when people talk about the first
ecstasy tablet you know everybody light
has that first because what happens is
you go to a new state a new place you
know yourself in a different way again
kid who recently got into ecstasy and
like you won't shut up about it yeah
it's like the thing maybe because it
gives them a state of being so like but
the problem a game with things like E is
if you feel a new state of joy then
you're a [__] state of depression feels
a lot lower and you have to be ready for
that I think what people need to do when
they start taking drugs is think about
what they are going to impact on the
recipes are like a rubber band effect
yeah it's just simple it's not like if
I've only ever known this is really
happy and now I'm like this is my really
happy then my sad is Sutter it can't
help that it's just the way it's the
wouldn't your Lord you really sad you
feel really sad I know that people are
always going to take drugs I think that
that's completely normal it's what we do
in our society but what we should be
doing is regular in the mall we should
tax the more we should make sure that
every single one of them is in a
situation where it's not going to kill
the person we should plow all the money
in tax insert rehabilitation and
education and more importantly we should
know that we get rid of street crime we
get rid of trafficking you know all the
sex trafficking to do with drugs the
bigger question is why do the government
not do that and they don't do it because
you know damn well what the impact would
be on our society wouldn't have guns we
wouldn't have all of this street street
traffic Amy we're never half there the
negativity going on would wipe it out
and when we do that it means it'll be
even more people asking questions of the
government and the prison system is down
keep us down keep us down and that's the
fact it's not it's me saying it's a fact
that is seven opinion but if you listen
to what I've just said you'll know what
I'm saying makes absolute sense so it
should be a fact I have my lifetime
that's my hope in my lifetime I get to
see that my hope in my lifetime is I get
to see regulation we'll all the European
countries are headed in that way so
hopefully that'll be Portugal did indeed
come unless everything 50% decrease in
addiction 50 cent increase in those who
have been addicts in to employment and
education it's worked the point is its
work so why I'm doing it all right
couple of coolant I suppose yeah it's
from a last looks like a teenage loss
why do easy girls always get the guy Oh
any of us regular girls get their
attention when we've quite happily play
a game of cod and eat pizza they play it
well she's just she feels a bit mean
things about girls get the car you saw
well I don't think there was an easy
girl
okay there's a girl who wants to have
sex as a girl who doesn't want to have
sex you know there's a girl who's
willing as a young person to for hours
as a girl who's not it's completely
subjective like I don't judge anyone if
you want to screw around with whoever
you want to screw around with do it but
if you're asking why are guys going for
the girl that will put out
well it's got nothing to do with you and
anything wrong with you it is to do with
the fact they want to have sex sex is
like really cannot convert Russian fun
it's exciting it's tantalizing it feels
fantastic and if there is a girl willing
to give the guy that and they're not
necessarily looking for a long-term
committed loving relationship they just
want a bit of fun then they're gonna do
that it's not that they're not going to
end up believe me
eating pizza chilling out and having fun
with you you're gonna find a guy who
absolutely takes you as you are who you
are look maybe don't see girls as easy
just see how anything is so sometimes if
if it go put so on the first day it
doesn't mean that she's not gonna love
the relationship you know as well cause
sometimes people just click to any
future girlfriends it's just making sure
that they're well completely see you
again after put it this way if you want
a second date with me then like having
sex that's definitely a best way to go
about it I mean but but you'll be
best-case scenario you know I think when
you're older that becomes more normal
that's true I think when you're young
person it's really strive like young
people get hassled when they don't put
out girls are so worried about having a
bad name yeah I mean one what girl
should always do is know that anyone who
gives you a bad name because you've
chosen to have sex that is just so
reductive it's such a redundant argument
so why are you doing kids girls you know
and actually the reason that some people
are seeking that kind of affection and
attention is not because they aim all
the names that associate date really
because they want attention because they
want to feel loved and we shouldn't
judge them by the same time I want to
tell everyone because they're loaded now
so I'm a tease meow in the UK you know
we talk about it a lot when the younger
desperate everybody wants it and then
like people get into marriages a lot of
the time and then end up hardly ever
having sex anymore it's like so screwed
of it like we don't do enough talking
about sex and actually having great sex
for learning about great sets you know
everybody should be having sex like
every single
Nighy if you're in a remote though I'm
ya know I'd say a ba-bling or something
getting all there is um can you not
believe me believe me go I actually have
started to appreciate like sort of the
the anticipation as well whereas when I
was younger it would just be like it has
to be all the time like as many times it
is not so yeah once but like if you go
say a day away from that person and you
haven't seen them for you
it's bear sure like with that actually
if you're living with them no no I'm
just saying so I'm just saying sometimes
like I've actually learned sometimes
makes the hut I'm growing I'm drawing as
a person and what I'm seeing is
sometimes waiting the D is good sex play
is really each other and all that anyway
and when I say yes I also think there's
a lot of pressure like like genuine like
as a as a educator and as some new Hyun
this area quite a lot I would definitely
say that having a really solid
confidence around sex is really
important so I do not think you should
have sex with anybody unless you feel
fully ready I don't think that you
should have sex because your mates
having sex I don't think you should have
sex because people are telling you you
should have sex because you're a virgin
don't just always know yourself like
genuinely like I look like at my first
sexual experience and it was great
it's great I'm wanting to have sex with
him he wanted to have sex with me I was
in a relationship that lasted a long
time at the time didn't end up marrying
him but at the end of the day I look
back at the first time it was not a bad
experience it was the opposite was a
really good experience because I was
ready I've said no to lots of guys
before but I was ready for him and women
reject a lot on them but also women when
they have thanks yeah but when they have
sex in the end a lot of women feel like
girls feel like they should you
shouldn't have to do that like when you
get confident about sex that happens
when you're ready so confidence that
until then one sex just practice 8pc
with the guy enjoy yeah pizza on you and
ecology on oil get ready so that when
you do meet the right guy you can do
yeah absolutely that would be a great
idea
I like that but believe me you will find
something he wants to be PISA with you
and have sex with you in the end when
you're ready and you should just be cool
with being that person oh this is this
is an interesting one the over diagnosis
of mental illnesses okay or the trend of
people romanticizing mental
so what we're saying earlier is we don't
talk about it enough but then you've got
those other people who seem to like
build a Carrera of being that victim or
whatever I want to be seeing this poor
pitiful me or whatever
do you have you ever looked at someone
and thought you're talking [__] that you
know yeah
you're literally pretending to be
depressed so that people will feel a
certain way about you I've never met
anybody who is pretending to the petrol
I genuinely never never met anybody in
therapy who was pretending to be
depressed I've met a lot of people who
once they realized they were depressed
maybe for a period of time that stopped
them moving on because they felt like
that was their answer I'm really
depressed that's why I can't go to work
that's why I can't get a boyfriend
that's why I can't get with my parents
because I'm depressed so they use that
as a hook to stop themselves moving
forward that's quite common
I know people I know people who doesn't
realize it oppressed people also don't
literally I know people who I don't I
try to be nice or whatever but I'm just
silently very aware that you are
actually you did not say that to them
how the [__] do you turn around to
someone I think it depressed about
someone that's why I'm aware that but
that's why you say it you say I love you
and I think you're really depressed and
I want to help you so that sort of so
with depression often I think comes
anger issues
as well and then the people I'm aware of
who I think are depressed have these
anger issues to the point where in order
to convince them of their depression I'm
going to have to have a massive [__]
argument where I have to go or remember
this and remember that and almost proven
and me not being qualified they're like
what the [__] do you know so I almost
stuff on the back but I think because
they lash out quite a bit as I just have
to sort of carry on yeah dealing with it
you should voice it that I'm good I'm
gonna but it's you know really the thing
is like Nick how the [__] do you tell
someone that you think there's someone
out there are probably wondering yeah I
would say it like I would genuinely say
what does they say well what do you know
well the thing is you can say well the
reason I'm saying it is because of a B
and C and also how
odd cast with two Geordie it's also how
you say I think I'm at mental illness is
lot lots of people don't realize they
depress that's why people kill
themselves by genuinely that's why
people kill themselves if people had
realized genuinely but what happened to
suicide and one of my really good
friends kill himself when I was like a
young woman and I can still remember us
the question after was was how did that
happen he was always so happy how did
that happen he was always okay and then
you realize that actually they were just
always acting that way because they were
trying to fit in and you look back and
you say to yourself
there must have been so many times that
his actions like at that point if we'd
asked could maybe have led to that
conversation what you're saying is
you're even further down that line this
person is acting in a way that looks
depressed so if they're already at that
point they were even further down the
line than that person who killed
themselves because they're actually
acting in a way that's quite depressed
so you have to reach out like I would
say to anybody and everybody is far
better to reach out and get some we
shower yeah some do you reject you for a
bit so let me tell you that you're wrong
but the knife heard it they've heard it
and you're like you know what the hero
you you just stop them being allowed to
hide from it people want to hide from it
guys in our society particularly boys
they are brought up with this ridiculous
schema that says Oh be strong you know
know how to cope we was off Lord I get
so many messages of human you have a
penis therefore you should also know how
to cope with the slings and arrows of
life no it's really hard look growing up
growing up in our society is something
that we're all told to be thankful for
because you know we come from Western
environment and even the poorest of the
poor Castelli and blah blah blah blah
actually somewhere like that emotions
don't were like I think grown woman now
must be the hardest is ever I think so
right now
Blair to compare what they used to be if
anything there was so much structure
back in like the forties fifties sixties
however they men it was very
straightforward of what it was to be a
man whereas now there is no formula
those the thing about or saying men
female with the some differences but to
some degree we're all human and human
beings are incredibly incredibly vast
you know the vast every human being has
got like so many different feelings so
in different thoughts so many different
identities so many different transitions
and recreations and you know
reinventions through your life that's
one of the things that young people
should be told you know I
learn that properly in my early 20s I
was like screw this I'll just reinvent
myself I don't need to do anything
drastic with my life and I don't need to
do anything awful to myself to change I
can just reinvent myself I'll just be a
totally different person
you go through shades and transitions
and changes and I think we need to teach
in people that so when they're sitting
there a14 thinking I don't have any
friends I'm not popular I'm being
bullied or that person doesn't fancy me
feels like the end of the world it's
like yeah it feels like the end of the
world it's just the end of this so what
do you want to do for your next part of
your world what you want to do for your
next transition why is all why are the
numbers of male suicides so high in your
is there what you've just been talking
about you think yeah I think the men I
think it's the biggest killer of women
as well don't get me wrong which is
that's higher for men I think because
guys are brought up constantly feeling
like it's not okay to cry it's no okay
to be demonstrative with your emotions
you've got to be hard you've got to be
cool I mean you look at when you're at
school right do you know I mean the nice
sensitive guy who is gonna be a
wonderful husband is often the person
being bullied the guys who are cool and
him with the in-crowd are scared
shitless and I got dropped from being in
the in-crowd so they're doing things
that they're not altogether comfortable
with two other people potentially just
to stay there you've got the most
popular guys to actually don't know how
to control and use their power
appropriately so they're doing things
that really they're gonna regret a few
dozen what years down the line and be
regretful of and then you've got the
girls at the same time kind of finding
the things attractive that in 5-10 years
time they're not going to find
attractive it's confusing but nobody
sits and says that to them and says make
choices based on who you are what you
want what you need not what you think
all the people think you should be I
think you should need nail tip
completely agree with who you actually
are know who you want people to see you
us yeah cuz the two different things and
also it's so bloody exhausting
that's the other thing you know you put
on this ridiculous cloak that doesn't
even belong to you that's like a
disguise that you think you're gonna be
and then you have to play it and act it
the whole time and you go home at night
you feel like you duplicitous because
you're not actually being the person you
truly are if you're not good because
you're thinking did I actually carry
that forward if people believe it from
to Placitas Tanaka
it's like being looted you're not it's
exhausting you have to check out with
you made sure that you made sense
nothing you wake up the next day you're
like oh I put that clip I kind of go
just like bu like bu it might mean you
lose some of your friends that's cool
because you'll find new friends who like
you for you you know bu because in the
end you might not get the guy or the
girl that you really like but you'll
find the person you reflects exactly
what you deserve bu because in the end
you will never have to make it effort
things will feel less less exhausting
and you'll feel happy that's what you
need to do it won't cure everybody's
mental health issues we don't make out
what easier someone you already
mentioned and also just also just to say
is well know that no matter where you
are particularly a young person you will
be loved by somebody you'll be
absolutely adored by somebody that's the
other point there's a big fear of I'll
be absolutely adored you will literally
be a dog there will be somebody who sees
you one day and you will take that
breath away and you won't know why and I
had somebody send to me yesterday you
know there's always gonna be a girl
prettier than me that's always get well
it's always gonna be a girl younger
prettier a tall or short or bigger
whatever it's always going to be
somebody don't compare yourself to that
because one day somebody's gonna walk
into your room and it's just gonna take
your breath away and it's gonna happen
for you and it's gonna be incredible and
then all you should ever do in that
moment is look at that person who
reflects your worth and spend your life
thinking [__] how lucky I am
how lucky cuz we've done something crazy
in our society in the past 50 years
we're taking the emphasis of being we're
taking the emphasis of meaning and we've
extrapolated over the way you look the
way you learn the job you do the house
you live in
[__] [__] the only thing that
matters is this tiny nucleus of being
with the person that you love or a
family you create or your extended from
with us around you that is having
meaning that is where happiness lives
that's where mental health lives that's
where truly truly feeling grateful lives
and it's small and it has [__] all to do
with the way you look or what you pay
packages or what you're gonna do in your
career doesn't matter so when you worry
about all that [__] that these young
people are writing in about when they're
worried about all that [__] it's Jack
all to do with happiness and it's there
and everyone can get it it's just right
there it's just acknowledge it yeah many
percent like we see enough for me
so it's so true and we we just spend our
lives chasing things that we're told
Mike was happy and then we're feeling
constantly like we're running into walls
because it's not real none like
obviously like I say I've gone on this
journey and then you some I think I
forget forget about our house or about a
car literally it's [__] the same
place in the [__]
genuinely my car till last year was
worth 200 pounds don't get me wrong you
have a nice little time when you first
get a new thing whatever that new thing
is you may have a new court new house
new car but it's all temporary six
months yeah still left with you and who
you are and that's what the real truth
is and then people will watch things
they'll watch videos you know of people
who've like gone off-grid and they'll be
captivated by these two incredibly happy
people with the little family and
they'll be like farming somewhere really
remote and not just be talking about the
fact that they work two days a year
doing whatever because that brings a
minute of money in and people are like
oh my god they seem really happy you're
like yes because they took the
fundamentals of happiness and just made
it into their whole world and the thing
about the capitalist state is we
convinced everybody and anybody who's
grown up in Western Britain we convinced
you that you have to have to be happy
you have to be rich you have to be
successful you have to be beautiful you
have to want a B and C use a credit card
buy that new thing because that'll make
you feel happier and it's all just
absolute crap it's volume it's the
day-to-day activities isn't it that's
what if you're doing what you love when
people say about why am I feeling
depressed go spending so much time
online for example like obviously I
think the online world's amazing I think
the cyber was incredible I think it's
such a democratic environment it also
connects people everywhere so it's great
but if you weren't going out every day
and talking to people that's the problem
so there are two indicators that will
mean that you live a long life one is
that you have close relationships so
that makes your life long and the second
is
interactions on a daily basis going out
and talking to as many people as
possible first about impacting your
mental health and well-being and
secondly it gives you a longer life yeah
so the thing about what we need is
humans are very small but we don't
actually teach people what they need we
just tell them a load of myths and
hopeful spend a lot of money so that our
capitalist state continues it's the way
it works well I've had a [__] good
chat with you
I know I just want to come back though
and just like through everything we've
got we've got shitload so we'll
definitely do a third one maybe Lawrence
will be here for that if I let him back
bless but the thing is the truth is
they're like to all the people who've
written in here worried about mental
health who worried about who they are
like when you're young really well then
yeah like what the [__] yeah no I'm like
yeah well if I don't do something like
what I'm saying [__] so I'm hoping
that what we've talked about the deer
can just push them in that way exactly
yeah and the point I do a clinic on a
Wednesday as well just a safe is free
online on Facebook Likes we'll leave all
the yeah I'll leave that second expert
no I do it free and it's like people
want to do I can do a special one for
that but the truth is if you're
listening now and you've asked about
mental health and well-being right it's
confusing being young mental health when
you're young is even more confusing
because you don't have the
responsibilities like pay mortgages
looking after kids having a job you know
there's nothing to anchor you to the
here and now so often you start running
wild with your thoughts but what you
need to know is this for the most part
anxiety and depression will pass 80% of
the time it passes 80% of time you'll
never feel it again so don't worry if
you've got depressed but if it's
constant and you're worried you do need
to seek some help but there are some
things you can do eat a healthy diet
exercise every single day I know that
sounds like an old wives tale it's
absolutely true do it go out in the
sunlight talk to your friends don't
Support Forums
get in touch with other community people
who need and can help you in the area
and baby step it to start with no sat on
pause so like alright I'm gonna do
exercise a 10 minute walk in the morning
or in the middle that just start with
that
understand build yourself yeah and
always remember this in the end you'll
find your way but you just have to stick
it just don't get all don't get like
that's it's similar but it's [__]
hard but if you do it you'll get
somewhere and also look at people like
you because people like you and people
like me both it entirely screwed at one
point did feel oh really
yes or the our audio links in the
description so they can follow you and
if you've enjoyed the chat don't forget
like the video subscribe we'll see as
there